swords in the darkness hi the black
brothers of the Nights Watch are that at
least there's too many of the free [ __ ]
no you southerners a strange a man
murders and you train him to kill better
her man thieves or rapes and he send him
where it's dark and private well this he
make him promise to be good well then
you make him regret even that from the
time he's walkin to the time he's
allowed to sleep he walks the frozen
wall carries frozen stones or boils
frozen food when he lies down at night
he can't have nobody to warm his frozen
bed well not unless the crows like to
nest together you think he remembers the
stories they told him then about when
the White Walkers work in the land of
always
and how the wall and the Nights Watch
were raised to stop them the next time
I never mind trapping us on the other
side Murray free folk have our stories -
about how one of your king crows found
something called
the woods with bright blue eyes how he
brought her home through your wall and
declared himself night's king in 13
years he and his queen ruled over his
brothers making sacrifices as black as
their clocks looking for you southerners
the free folk rallied to a
king-beyond-the-wall as we will when
need be and march on the ancient castle
he taken for his own the night thought
with the help of the Starks we killed
the demons and cleansed your precious
watch and then they thanked us and
kicked us back across a wall as you
always have Kendall RAM and red beard
the Horned Lord each Troezen as a
king-beyond-the-wall
each promising victory and all fallen to
the Nights Watch and the Starks
but this time is different our new king
knows your tricks
you called him a brother crawl once but
he never forgot his wings we know how
you think we know where you're weak
watch for us from your wall if you like
weather cold you won't even feel the
blade slip into your back